Transcriber: Daniel Wieber
المدقّق: Christin Melad
عادةً ما تبدأ قصص النجاح برؤية،
وأنجح الرؤى هي تلك
التي تُبنى على مكامن القوة.
هكذا بدأ حديثه سمو سيدي وَلِيُّ الْعَهْدِ
قائد وسط التغيير
ومهندس رؤية الوطن الطموحة 2030،
حينما أعلن الرؤية في 2016.
من أبرز مرتكزات هذه الرؤية الطموحة
للإستثمار في رأس المال البشري،
وعندما نتحدث عن هذا الموضوع يأتي في بالنا
دائمًا الإقتصاد المبني على المعرفة.
بكل تأكيد عندما نتحدث عن استثمار في العقول
يأتي برنامج خادم الحرمين الشريفين للإبتعاث
الخارجي كأفضل نموذج في الاستثمار في العقول
عندما انطلق هذا البرنامج
منذ أكثر من سبعة عشر عام،
لكن كان أَوْج عَطَائِهِ في أخر سبع سنوات،
عندما حددت وزارة التعليم قائمة
بجامعات النُخبة،
أيضًا أبرز التخصصات والتخصصات النوعية،
لترسل سفراء الوطن لينهلوا من العلم
ما يحقق رؤية وطنهم وأهدافهم المستدامة.
دائما ما أقول المبتعثون سفراء وطن،
وحملة إرث عظيم ورسالة سامية،
فمن واجبهم أن يسمع العالم صوت وطنهم،
ويرسم صورته المشرقة ودوره الحضاري العظيم.
اليوم نعيش هذه الرؤية الطموحة.
خلال مشاهداتي لعشر سنوات
في مقر الإبتعاث في المملكة المتحدة
وأيضًا مقار الإبتعاث الأخرى،
أجد المُبْتَعِثِي السعودي لِيَسُّوا فقط
متلقي للمعرفة كما يعتقد البعض.
العكس تمامًا،
هم أيضًا مشاركين في صناعة المعرفة ونقلها
والتأثير في من حولهم
من خلال مبادرات تطوعية ومشاركات مجتمعية،
تدريس في مقار أبرز الجامعات وكبرى الشركات،
وعندنا نماذج جدًا ناجحة
حصلت في دول الإبتعاث المختلفة.
أيضًا حراكهم الريادي والتطوعي
من خلال جعل بصمة تُحرك وتُساهم
بشكل فاعل في الدبلوماسية الثقافية.
وجعل حراك يقوده شباب الوطن
في مقار الإبتعاث المختلفة.
قصص النجاح الموجودة قد يتساءل البعض،
“كيف نجحوا طيب؟”
“كيف استطاعوا أنهم يحققون هذه النجاحات؟”
ثلاث تَّسَاؤُلات أجابوا عليها،
التَّسَاؤُل الأول قالوا:
“سأبدأ ب وسأتوقف عن وسأستمر على”
هذه الثلاث تَّسَاؤُلات جعلت لهم خارطة طريق
ناجحة خلال مسيرتهم ليس فقط في الدراسة،
بل أيضًا نجاحات أخرى مثل ما ذكرت
ريادية وتطوعية وأخرى.
إِذاً هي إلتزام وامتناع،
إلتزام بتحقيق الأهداف التي وضعوها لأنفسهم
وامتناع عن كل الْمُشَتِّتات.
كوننا نعيش في رؤية وطن طموح.
مواطن مسؤول.
هذه الرؤية الطموحة جعلتنا
لا نتحرك من العدم ولا ننطلق في الفراغ.
لدينا برنامج
اسمه برنامج تعزيز الشخصية السعودية.
هذا البرنامج يُعنَى بالتفكير وتعزيز
المهارات الخاصة بشباب الوطن،
قِيَم ومهارات ومعارف.
يستطيع الشاب السعودي
أن يجعل من نفسه مواطنًا عالميًا
يتسم بالقيادة والتفاؤل والطموح والرؤية
والتواصل والقدرة على التفكير الناقد،
جعل من نفسه مواطن عالمي.
هذه المُزاوجة الناجحة
استطاعت أن تجعل المواطن السعودي
والشعب السعودي نموذجًا عالميًا،
على سبيل المثال لا الحصر.
هذا الشعار موجود أمامكم.
“2030 رؤية طموحة.”
هذه مبادرة رَوَّاهَا المبتعثين
في مقار البعثة وخاصة في المملكة المتحدة.
هو شعار مثل ما تشوفون “همة حتى القمة”
الوصول ل2030.
ساهموا في نشر مفهوم
الرؤية 2030 وأهدافها،
مرتكزاتها الثلاث وأهدافها الـ96
وبرامجها العشر.
استطاعوا أنهم فعلاً يروون
هذه المبادرة بكل حب وبكل عطاء.
تلقت المبادرة دعم سخي
ورعاية من سمو سفير خادم الحرمين الشريفين
في المملكة المتحدة.
واستطاعت أن تحرك هذا الملف
بشكل جيد في ما يسمى بالدبلوماسية الثقافية.
هذه الفعالية هي دبلوماسية ناعمة،
هي قوة ناعمة.
صحيح أن يكون أثرها بالغ القوة،
لكن ترى بالمناسبة سهلة جدًا
على من أراد أن يساهم فعلاً
في تحقيق هذه المرتكزات المهمة.
للمساهمة في أي تغيير يتطلب أمرين،
أن يعرف وأن يعترف.
أن يعرف الرؤية وأهدافها
وبرامجها ومرتكزاتها،
وأن يعترف بدوره كشاب وشابة.
وعليه مسؤولية أن يقدم
نموذج يُحتذى به في هذا الأمر.
العمل التطوعي وفق 2030
يرتكز على مبدأ المواطن مسؤول،
فطموح الوطن يتجلى في مواطنه
فهو روحه وقلبه النابض.
فإذا أردنا أن نحقق التنمية حقيقة
فعلينا أن نتّسامى بالريادة والتطوع.
بين المملكتين هو هاشتاغ.
هو وسم عالمي
يحوي في طياته العديد من المشاركات
توضح الدور وتعمق العلاقة بين
المملكة العربية السعودية والمملكة المتحدة،
كنموذج فقط لقوة الحراك السعودي
على الخارطة الدولية.
في هذا الأمر نستطيع أن نشاهد
العديد من المبادرات التطوعية.
لعل اليوم حتشوفون على TEDX
بعض هذه المبادرات،
لكن يجب أن نقف لنتحدث
عن سفراء رياديون بشكل موجز.
هذه المبادرة انطلقت لتؤكد
دور العمل التطوعي الاحترافي.
الريادة الاجتماعية كمفهوم
مهم جدًا في الرؤية السعودية،
ليكون فعلاً بذلك خير سفراء لأغلى وطن.
المبادرة الجميل فيها أنها لم تتوقف
في المملكة المتحدة.
حطت رحالها هنا في المملكة العربية السعودية
وبالتحديد في الرياض،
بالشراكة مع عدد من شركاء نجاح
في القطاع الأول والثاني والثالث،
فاستطاعت أن تساهم بشكل فاعل في هذا الأمر.
واليوم نحن موجودين على خشبة TEDx
في كلية الشرق العربي مشكورة.
تسعى للمبادرة أن تكون فعلاً أداة
لتفعيل دبلوماسية ثقافية بين البلدين
وهي دائمًا متواجدة
في الفعاليات المختلفة بين المملكتين.
هو وسم قصة نجاح يجب أن تروى ولا تطوى،
وهي في طياتها بإذن اللَّه  يعني كتاب
سيصدر قريبًا بهذا الوسم بين المملكتين.
عَلَّمنِي التطوع أن التطوع ليس ترف،
بل أسلوب حياة يساهم ويعكس
خيرية الأفراد وأيضًا المجتمع.
يعكس فهمهم ووعيهم لحاضرهم وأيضًا مستقبلهم.
عَلَّمنِي التطوع خلال رحلة الإبتعاث
أن الإبتعاث أكثر من مجرد شهادة.
الشهادة ممكن نحصل عليها في أي مكان.
ممكن نحصل عليها هنا في أرقى الجامعات.
جامعات المملكة العربية السعودية
متقدمة جدًا بحثيًا وعلميًا،
لكن الأمر أعمق من هذا.
نتكلم عن أثر سعودي نصنعه
وبصمة تُترك في بلد الإبتعاث،
والفهم الثقافي العميق ليكون
في دول الإبتعاث المختلفة.
عَلَّمنِي التطوع أنه من خلال التطوع
نستطيع تحريك الدبلوماسية الثقافية
من خلال العديد من المبادرات.
من هم شركاء النجاح؟
الملحقية الثقافية عليها دور كبير
أن تقوم بهذا الأمر.
أيضًا المبتعثون عليهم مسؤولية
أن يبادروا ويأخذوا زمام الأمور،
ويطلبوا أيضًا الدعم من الملحقية
ويقدموا أنفسهم كنموذج.
علمني التطوع أننا نعم نستطيع
أن نعيش  بما نكسب،
لكننا حقيقة نحيا بما نعطي.
عَلَّمنِي التطوع أن الفرد السعودي
متى ما كان في أَوْج عَطَائِهِ،
في قمة أدائه على صعيد الأداء المتزن
والتفوق الباهر والأداء العظيم،
يستطيع أن يضع إسم المملكة العربية السعودية
على خارطة الطريق،
ويقول سعودي مر من هنا،
وهذا الأثر.
شكرا لكم.
(تصفيق)